[Music]
well the big orange meanie has struck
again
today I'm instructing my administration
to halt funding of the World Health
Organization while a review is conducted
to assess the World Health
Organization's role in severely
mismanaging and covering up the spread
of the corona virus had the w-h-o done
its job to get medical experts into
China to objectively assess the
situation on the ground and to call out
China's lack of transparency the
outbreak could have been contained at
its source
with very little death and as if on cue
the media spewed this is an attempt by
the President to steer you away from his
own actions if you go through the
scapegoats that he's blamed so far for
this coronavirus pandemic the WHL
members of the news media Democrats in
Congress what you're seeing is a
president who deflects demeans and
denounces others as opposed to taking
responsibility if I had to sum it up I
would say sheer madness it's obscene
it's strictly political when he's
accusing the w-h-o of he did even worse
madness obscene it's a reaction we've
come to expect from the children in the
room none of whom cared much about the
pandemic because they were too busy
smoking the crack pipe of impeachment
but are you surprised by Trump's actions
are you like the meat in which every day
is the first day of trump's presidency
no you get it
Trump strategy from day one is based on
incentives he asks how can we expect the
w-h-o to do better if they're going to
get our Millions anyway the w-h-o is
like everything in Trump's orbit he's
gonna kick its tires demand oversight
threatened to pull out nothing is
off-limits especially an organization
notorious for abuse Trump just spanked
its leadership who spent lavishly on
travel just so they could be China's
mouthpiece if they're housed in an order
why are we paying their rent you know
it's a good question when the media
won't ask
of course they pretend that this is the
end of the process when it's really just
the start
Trump shakes the box to see what happens
next it's not new but it works which is
why yesterday Obama spent 12 minutes
saying nothing to defend Joe it all
hinged on personality yeah Trump's mean
but Joe's nice unless your name is Terra
problem with Barack's defense the proof
that the stock market crashed when Trump
reamed Acosta did unemployment rise when
Trump invented a nickname no all Obama
had was a complaint that's as gray as he
is yeah we get it mr. Trump is mean but
he's mean on our behalf and the media
implodes because Trump dares to demand
competence for people soaking us for
millions I guess if it were Biden mr.
nice guy would have just sniffed their
hair and called it a day you know Dana I
like to offer solutions when there are
problems and if you notice what
President Trump said he said suspended
while a review is being performed so
this is the beginning of a process to
find a solution which I would think
would be to fund directly so we can
watch the money let our state department
administer the health funds directly in
country so we can see what's going on
more transparency right I think that's
probably right that at the at the end of
this process when it's finished that
you'll basically have the United States
I think still probably paying the lion's
share but also then utilizing the
influence that comes with that but we
are the superpower and we should act
like it so therefore we're gonna be here
and there's going to be a minder and
there's a United States person that's
going to be involved and I think there
are some good things that the WH Doh
doh-doh does for developing countries in
particular and when an outbreak like
Ebola happens like it's really important
that somebody is on the scene to be able
to help to try to stamp that down
because more failed States is not good
for anybody in the world so there's that
but when it comes to protecting our own
health if we're going
pay for the money then we should be able
to get something for it I don't think
that it will all go away unless there's
complete and total resistance you know
if the w-h-o decides that it just wants
to thumb its nose at America then you
might see America pull its funding out
and at that point it would probably be
the right thing to do yeah you know
Kennedy I think was 2018 they spent over
200 million dollars on travel expenses
and meanwhile they were having you know
they were having issues with a bullet
you know they were having shortfalls
they couldn't get the money what do you
what do you make of this I always think
it's a good idea to take a look at these
massive expenditures figure out where
the money's going figure out some
transparency and accountability I don't
have a problem with that
if the whu-oh is spending so much money
on transportation and travel why didn't
they go to China with a group of
international experts including
including epidemiologist from the United
States and really figure out the origin
of this virus because there are so many
unanswered questions and I really don't
think now is the time to defend or
appease China and I don't mind if we
take politicization out of the entire
picture but I I don't have a problem
with asking these important questions
and I think we should do that with every
government body who has dropped the ball
in in some area whether it's the federal
government on the state level or these
massive international conglomerates that
at this point are doing a little more
harm than good
what do you think that the w-h-o is is
the victim in this and and we're
politicizing this story and and it's it
seems like the media immediately
whenever Trump doesn't like something
the media always likes the thing he
doesn't like and when he likes something
they always take the opposition so isn't
that kind of what's going on here no but
I mean I always take the media out of it
for a second Greg I just think you can
have two realities one is I think China
lies a lot and lied about this virus and
the president is right when he calls
them out I wish he would do it more but
secondly that the w-h-o takes a lot on
face value and tries to work with these
governments that maintain or
their sovereignty so they need them to
cooperate in order for the w-h-o to do
their job so you have these two
conflicting realities so I think the
president is right to say hey why don't
why doesn't China stop lying I think he
should instead of lashing out at WH o
lash out of China but I think right now
to do what he's doing in the midst of a
global pandemic is a little bit like
cutting off your nose to spite your face
we need we don't even have a replacement
nobody in the world level is in the
position of the w-h-o to help us deal
with this crisis at the moment we can't
as the united states stop it unless we
deal with the developing countries and
even with China again because right now
I understand there may be facing a
second wave in that country so all of
that is important and I think in terms
of the politics of it you know apart
from the president putting his signature
on stimulus checks it is it is like he's
trying to distract us from all the
critics who say he's had some problems
in terms of his response what do you
think Jesse you think that's the case
well no to Juan's point the w-h-o is
there to prevent pandemics and they blew
it so that's over they're useless now
they're not there to cure pandemics
they're there to prevent and they failed
let me just show you a snapshot of the
w-h-o it's rotten from the top the
Chairman dr. Tadros do you know who he
actually gave a goodwill ambassador ship
to Robert Mugabe of Zimbabwe the
backlash was so strong he had to rescind
it this guy is from the Marxist
revolutionary party in Ethiopia he was
part of a regime there that had really
brutal crackdowns Human Rights
atrocities galore this 200 million
dollars they spent in one year on travel
is more than they spent fighting malaria
aids and tuberculosis combined they were
booking presidential suites with marble
bathrooms they were doing first-class
air they were doing luxury limousines so
now you have this slush fund run by a
Marxist basically an American expense
account and it's under the UN umbrella
I remind everybody about the United
Nations I mean this is like for Arab
dictatorships European socialist
third-world wannabes and they're all
just trying to take down America
it's a patronage mill and we pay for
that patronage mill and oil for food the
rape scandals in Africa I mean they
predicted Manhattan would be under water
last year this hold WH o UN scene is a
bad scene
they have a lot of meetings and they'd
ever do anything we got to make sure we
get it right yeah I think you summed it
up perfectly